[Music]
what are you two doing
why aren't you interrupting rehearsal
with your lab talk what's what are you
up to
a likely story we were laughing at your
jokes that's the worst lie I've ever
heard this island of misfit toys a
squirt gun that shoots lemonade a Jill
in the box
that's a reference I don't even know if
it makes sense anymore I went to these
kids I don't know if they know at the
end of this week it's a Jill in the box
and it's a no it's a nobody wants a
Charlie in the bar a Charlie in the box
you're right nobody wants to try that
with a squirt gun shoot Shelley oh it
shoots jelly I thought it was grape
jelly yeah it's a shoot you train with
square wheels
yeah a doll a sharp razor like teeth no
wait that's Barbarella
was it a dvd-r but it's not like it was
oh my god it's coming on it's on in
three weeks I'm so excited
that's it was the man that you saw it on
demand well it was on demand and that
you put a tape in when you felt like
watching but you had a tape it was just
you could watch it in July if you wanted
well let me tell you how it used to be
gather round kids yeah it was a big deal
it was on in two weeks we couldn't watch
TV during the week but we'd say we've
got to watch Christmas specials yeah it
ran on oat bran we were so excited and
then it would come time we'd watch it
but then the news would come in about
Vietnam
they'd been open for three years it had
been over for a long time
[Music]